[Música]
Yair bolsonaro rompió el silencio pero
no reconoció explícitamente su derrota
de este domingo frente a Lula la Silva
en las elecciones de Brasil sin embargo
sí autorizó iniciar la transición de
poder el presidente también retiró su
apoyo a los bloqueos de Los camioneros
en rechazo a la victoria del
izquierdista
Gustavo Petro y Nicolás Maduro dijeron
que se comprometen a seguir trabajando
conjuntamente en diversos temas de
Colombia y Venezuela así lo anunciaron
los propios mandatarios tras una reunión
en Caracas la primera en seis años entre
dos presidentes de estos países
nuevo estado de excepción en Ecuador el
presidente Guillermo lasso anunció que
la medida empezó en las provincias de
guayas y esmeraldas luego de una serie
de hechos violentos que han provocado la
muerte de varias personas
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en francés 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Brasil tras más de 40 horas de silencio
el presidente Jair bolsonaro se
pronunció sobre las elecciones
presidenciales del domingo pero no
reconoció oficialmente su derrota ni
felicitó a su rival Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva desde el Palacio de La Alborada y
tras una reunión con su equipo de
ministros el mandatario compareció ante
la prensa y dijo que siempre ha
obedecido fielmente la Constitución y
que seguirá haciéndolo fue su jefe de
gabinete quien se encargó de confirmar a
los medios que el mandatario autorizó el
inicio del proceso de transición de
poder el supremo tribunal Federal dijo
que con dicha autorización bolsonaron
está reconociendo el resultado final el
líder de la ultraderecha perdió las
elecciones del pasado 30 de octubre por
un muy estrecho margen de
49,1% contra el 50,9% de la izquierdista
como el presidente de la república es un
ciudadano continuaré cumpliendo todos
los mandatos de la constitución
soy ahora el líder de millones de
brasileños que como ahora defiendo la
libertad religiosa la libertad de
opinión la honestidad
y los colores del verde y amarillo de
nuestra bandera Muchas gracias
y luego del Triunfo de Lula da Silva por
primera vez en la historia a las cinco
principales economías latinoamericanas
estarán gobernadas por la izquierda sin
embargo el panorama actual Está marcado
por la recesión económica y desafíos
mundiales que opacan sus ambiciosas
propuestas
se vive el renacimiento de la izquierda
en Latinoamérica por primera vez en la
historia a las cinco principales
economías de la región estarán
gobernadas por el izquierdismo el mapa
empezó a dibujarse en julio de 2018 con
El Triunfo de Andrés Manuel López
Obrador en México le siguió Alberto
Fernández en Argentina en 2019 y se
completó con Gabriel borich en chile y
Gustavo Petro en Colombia la izquierda
también hace presencia en Venezuela Cuba
Nicaragua Perú o Bolivia sin embargo la
fuerza progresista de este tiempo tiene
un panorama mucho más difícil que el de
la marea rosa de comienzos de siglo
cuando Venezuela Argentina chile Brasil
Bolivia y Uruguay tenían mandatarios de
izquierda en esa época sus gobiernos
gozaban de tener los precios de sus
materias primas por las nubes y nos
enfrentaban a las consecuencias
económicas de una pandemia la crisis de
suministro por la guerra en Ucrania y
una inflación generalizada en septiembre
el índice de precios al consumidor Fue
de más de dos dígitos para la mayoría de
los países de la región algunos incluso
están en recesión y se espera que por lo
menos dos de ellos superan El 100% de la
tasa inflacionaria para final de año y a
pesar del gasto fiscal de los gobiernos
muchos ciudadanos pasaron de la clase
media la pobreza en un panorama de
desaceleración del crecimiento el fondo
monetario internacional la cepal y otras
instituciones económicas han rebajado
las expectativas de crecimiento para la
mayoría de los países de la región que
en 2023 crecerá apenas un 1,4%
. muchos de los presidentes recién
elegidos ya han mermado en el porcentaje
de nivel de aprobación mientras intentan
cumplir sus promesas de pacto tal la
erradicación del hambre la
redistribución de la riqueza la equidad
social y la preservación del medio
ambiente el presidente colombiano
Gustavo Petro visitó Caracas donde se
reunió con Nicolás Maduro ambos
acordaron seguir trabajando en conjunto
en diferentes áreas para el pleno
restablecimiento de las relaciones entre
ambos países
un presidente de Colombia de vuelta a
Venezuela Gustavo Petro se reunió con su
homólogo Nicolás Maduro en el Palacio de
Miraflores sin grandes anuncios pero
Aparentemente más cerca del regreso de
Venezuela a las instituciones regionales
sobre los pasos en función de una
reconcidación del sistema interamericano
de Derechos Humanos he sido muy
receptivo
y así será en el transcurso las próximas
semanas en relaciones este interesante
tema planteado por el presidente Gustavo
Petro los jefes de estado hablaron entre
otros asuntos de una mayor colaboración
migratoria de liderar la preservación de
la selva del Amazonas y de la necesidad
de fortalecer el intercambio comercial
Petro acusa a las mafias de controlar la
frontera vamos a reconstruir incluso las
relaciones que había a nivel de
inteligencia
para poder golpear ya no tanto al obrero
del narcotráfico que por ahí anda sino a
los dueños del capital que son los que
casi nunca se han golpeado Colombia Miss
Venezuela reabrieron su frontera de
2.200 kilómetros en septiembre después
de tener el paso restringido desde 2015
y bloqueado por completo desde 2019
también hacía años que no se veían un
presidente colombiano y su homólogo
venezolano la última vez fue en 2016 en
un encuentro entre Nicolás maduro y Juan
Manuel Santos en la frontera venezolana
Gustavo Petro se posesionó el 7 de
agosto y ese mismo mes anunció la
restauración de relaciones diplomáticas
con Venezuela una nueva era después de
que durante el gobierno de Iván Duque
Colombia fuese uno de los 60 países que
reconocieron a Juan guaidó como la
autoridad en Venezuela
en Ecuador el presidente Guillermo lasso
declaró el estado de excepción y toque
de queda en dos provincias del país la
medida empezó a regir desde este martes
en guayas donde una serie de ataques
dejó al menos dos policías muertos y
otros dos heridos según autoridades se
registró la detonación de al menos siete
explosivos esmeraldas también entra en
estado de excepción luego de que se
registrara la muerte de dos personas en
hechos violentos
estoy declarando el estado de excepción
en las provincias de guayas y esmeraldas
y el toque de queda a partir de las
nueve de la noche estamos tomando
acciones que los tienen preocupados por
eso la reacción violenta
estos actos de Sabotaje y terrorismo son
Por así decirlo una declaratoria de
guerra abierta contra el estado de
derecho el gobierno y contra todos
ustedes los ciudadanos el primero y el 2
de noviembre se conmemora en México y en
Centroamérica el día de los muertos así
como en varios países de Sudamérica
donde lo celebran los pueblos
originarios en Guatemala construyen
gigantescas cometas conocidas como
barriletes o papalotes que usan para
enviar mensajes a sus difuntos nuestros
corresponsales en Centroamérica llegaron
a Zumpango el municipio donde la muerte
cobra color en el cielo
[Música]
en la noche Es cuando ocurre la magia
este grupo de artistas está montando la
estructura que en la mañana sostendrá
las gigantescas cometas de papel de
china que hicieron famoso hace un pango
este pueblo de Guatemala
y como la armazón es en plena noche y
estamos Pues justo en la luna Bajo la
Luna verdad por eso que alcanza un pan
con Nosotros le llamamos la luna del
barrilete ni vas a dormir por la emoción
Juan Pablo se unió a la tradición desde
sus 12 años pero es la primera vez que
participa en la exhibición con su grupo
ahí nomás por qué hacer barriletes pues
cuentan que al momento de que el papel
china cuando uno no eleva choca con el
viento ese sonido que provoca no le
gusta a los malos espíritus después de
desvelarse toda la noche los artistas
reciben la madrugada y a las 200.000
personas que acoge el evento se arreglan
los últimos detalles artísticos y
empieza la demostración para comunicarse
con los muertos vamos una fiesta de
sincretismo católico que se mezcla con
la tradición indígena de Mesoamérica
las energías de los muertos que que se
han ido
a la hora de nosotros estamos espantando
ahí en el más allá es donde tienen que
pertenecer y no mantener a molestar a
los vivos
esta tradición de de un siglo evolucionó
con la aparición de grupos de artistas
de mujeres los gestos de los expertos
para hacer volar los enormes barriletes
se siguen transmitiendo de manera oral
[Música]
una herencia cultural que sigue poniendo
por lo alto literalmente la cultura maya
[Música]
hasta que este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]